qui va embrouiller le cerveau du criquet,
le faisant se comporter de façon erratique.
Quand le criquet se retrouve près d'une source d'eau,
comme une piscine,
il va sauter dedans et se noyer,
et le ver va pouvoir sortir
de ce corps suicidaire.
Les criquets sont vraiment très spacieux ! Qui l'aurait cru ?
Le ver plat et le nématomorphe ne sont pas uniques.
Ils font partie d'un grand groupe
de parasites manipulateurs,
de champignons, virus, vers, insectes et d'autres
qui sont tous spécialisés dans le détournement
de la volonté de leurs hôtes.
J'ai appris que ces parasites existaient
dans un documentaire de David Attenborough
il y a à peu près 20 ans,
et ensuite grâce à un livre merveilleux
de mon ami Carl Zimmer "Parasite Rex".
Et depuis, je n’arrête pas d’écrire sur ces créatures.
C'est vraiment un sujet qui me passionne.
C'est comme si ces parasites avaient détourné mon propre cerveau.
Parce qu'après tout, ils sont toujours captivants
et ils sont délicieusement macabres.
Quand vous écrivez sur les parasites,
votre vocabulaire s'enrichit d'expressions telles que
« dévoré vivant » et « explosé hors de son corps ».
(Rires)
Mais il y a bien d'autres choses.
Je suis écrivain, et les écrivains,
ça adore les histories.
Les parasites nous invitent à résister
aux histoires trop flagrantes.
Leur monde est plein de rebondissements
et d'explications inattendues.
Pourquoi, par exemple,
cette chenille se met
à frapper violemment autour d'elle
quand un autre insecte s'approche
trop près de ces cocons blancs
qu'il a l'air de vouloir défendre ?
Essaye-t-il de protéger ses frères et sœurs ?
Non.
Cette chenille s'est faite attaquer
par une guêpe parasite qui a pondu des œufs en elle.
Les œufs ont éclos et les jeunes guêpes
ont dévoré la chenille vivante
avant d'exploser hors de son corps.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
Mais, la chenille n'est pas morte.
Quelques guêpes se sont attardées
et l'ont obligé à défendre leurs frères et sœurs
qui sont en train de se métamorphoser
en adulte à l'intérieur de ces cocons.
Cette chenille est un garde du corps zombie qui fait du handbang
en défendant la progéniture
de la créature qui l'a tuée.
(Applaudissements)
J'ai beaucoup de choses à dire et je n'ai que 13 minutes. (Rires)
Certains d’entre vous essayent sans doute
désespérément de se raccrocher
à l'idée que ce sont des curiosités
du monde naturel, que c'est rare
et c'est compréhensible,
parce que par nature, les parasites sont tous petits
et ils passent beaucoup de temps
dans les corps d'autres choses.
Ils sont faciles à ignorer,
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils ne sont pas importants.
Il y a quelques années, Kevin Lafferty
a amené un groupe de scientifiques dans trois estuaires californiens
et ils ont pesé et disséqué
et enregistré tout ce qu'ils trouvaient,
et ce qu'ils ont trouvé
étaient une abondance de parasites.
Les plus courants étaient les trématodes,
des petits vers spécialisés dans la castration de leurs hôtes
comme ce malheureux escargot.
Un seul trématode est minuscule,
mais tous ensemble ils pesaient plus
que tous les poissons des estuaires
et de trois à neuf fois plus que tous les oiseaux.
Et rappelez vous le ver gordien que je vous ai montré,
celui avec le criquet ?
Un scientifique japonais, Takuya Sato
a trouvé que dans un ruisseau,
ces vers amènent tellement de criquets
et de sauterelles dans l'eau
que ces insectes noyés
fournissent jusqu'à 60 pour cent de la nourriture des truites.
La manipulation n'est pas bizarre.
C'est une partie importante et fréquente
du monde qui nous entoure,
et les scientifiques ont trouvé
des centaines d'exemples de manipulations,
et ils commencent même à comprendre
comment ces créatures arrivent à contrôler leurs hôtes.
Celui-ci est mon exemple préféré.
C'est l'Ampulex compressa,
la guêpe cafard émeraude.
C'est reconnu universellement
qu'une de ces guêpes en possession
d’œufs fertilisés
va chercher à se procurer un cafard.
Quand elle l'a trouvé,
elle le pique avec son dard
qui est aussi un organe de sens.
On a fait cette découverte il y a trois semaines.
Elle le pique de son dard
équipé de petites bosses sensorielles
qui lui permet de ressentir la texture
du cerveau du cafard.
Comme quelqu'un farfouillant dans un sac,
elle trouve le cerveau, et y injecte un poison
à deux endroits très précis.
Les scientifiques israéliens Frederic Libersat et Ram Gal
ont découvert que ce poison était une arme chimique puissante.
Il ne tue pas le cafard, il ne l'endort pas non plus.
Le cafard pourrait s'en aller
ou s'envoler ou partir en courant s'il le voulait,
mais il décide de rester là
parce que ce poison lui enlève sa motivation de marcher,
et c'est tout ce qu'il fait !
La guêpe efface l'alarme "attention-danger-s-enfuir"
dans le système opératoire du cafard,
lui permettant de ramener sa victime sans défense
jusqu'à son repaire par ses antennes
comme quelqu'un promenant son chien.
Une fois sur place, elle pond ses œufs dessus,
les œufs éclosent, dévoré vivant, explosé hors de son corps,
et cetera, et cetera, vous connaissez la suite.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Moi je dirais, que une fois piqué,
le cafard n'est plus un cafard.
C'est plus une extension de la guêpe,
comme le criquet était une extension du ver gordien.
Ces hôtes ne survivront pas et ne se reproduiront pas.
Ils contrôlent leur destin
comme ma voiture.
Une fois que les parasites sont à l'intérieur,
les hôtes n'ont plus rien à dire.
Les humains, bien sur,
savent bien ce que c'est la manipulation.
On prend des drogues pour changer la chimie de nos cerveaux
et pour changer nos humeurs,
et les débats, la publicité ou les grandes idées
sont des bons exemples de manipulation de l'esprit de quelqu'un.
Mais nos techniques de manipulation
sont grossières et maladroites comparées
à celles bien spécifiques des parasites.
Don Draper rêve d'être aussi élégant
et précis que la guêpe cafard émeraude.
C'est ce qui rend les parasites
aussi sinistres et aussi attirants.
On a une telle assurance dans notre libre arbitre
et notre indépendance
que l'idée de les perdre
à des forces invisibles
nourrit beaucoup de nos peurs sociétales les plus primales.
Les contre-utopies orwelliennes et les cabales de l'ombre
et les super-vilains qui contrôlent nos esprits,
sont les stéréotypes de nos fictions les plus sombres,
mais dans la nature, ça arrive tous les jours.
Ce qui m'amène à une question
flagrante et dérangeante :
Y'a-t-il des parasites sinistres
qui influencent nos comportements
sans que nous le sachions,
à part la NSA ?
S'il y en a ---
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
J'ai un point rouge sur le front maintenant?
(Rires)
S'il y en a, voici un très bon candidat pour eux.
Voici Toxoplasma gondii, ou Toxo pour les amis,
parce qu'une créature terrifiante
à toujours droit à un joli surnom.
Toxo infecte les mammifères,
beaucoup de mammifères,
mais il ne peut se reproduire que dans un chat.
Et des scientifiques comme Joanne Webster ont démontré que
si Toxo infecte un rat ou une souris,
il va faire du rongeur un missile cherche-cat.
Si le rat infecté sent l'odeur
de pipi de chat,
il va courir dans la direction de l'odeur
plutôt que s'enfuir comme il devrait le faire.
Le chat mange le rat. Toxo va pouvoir se reproduire.
C'est le conte classique : mange, chasse, aime.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Vous êtes très gentils et généreux.
Salut, Elizabeth, j'ai adoré ta présentation.
Comment le parasite
contrôle-t-il son hôte ?
On ne sait pas trop.
On sait que Toxo relâche une enzyme
qui crée de la dopamine, une substance impliquée
dans la récompense et la motivation.
On sait qu'il cible certaines parties du cerveau du rongeur,
y compris celles impliquées dans l'excitation sexuelle.
Mais comment toutes ces pièces de puzzle s'emboitent-elles
n'est pas très clair.
Ce qui est clair est que cette chose
est une cellule unique.
Il n'a pas de système nerveux.
Il n'a pas de conscience.
Il n'a même pas de corps.
Et il arrive à manipuler un mammifère ?
Nous sommes des mammifères.
Nous sommes plus intelligents qu'un rat, évidemment,
mais nos cerveaux ont la même structure de base,
le même genre de cellules,
les mêmes éléments chimiques,
et les mêmes parasites.
Les estimations varient mais certaines statistiques suggèrent
qu'une personne sur trois dans le monde
aurait Toxo dans son cerveau.
Heureusement, ça ne mène généralement à aucune maladie grave.
Le parasite reste là, endormi
pendant très longtemps.
Mais, il a été démontré que ces gens
porteurs obtiennent des scores différents
à des questionnaires de personnalité que d'autres personnes,
qu'ils sont plus à risque d'avoir un accident de voiture,
et il y a même des preuves que les personnes atteintes de schizophrénie
sont plus à même d'être infectées.
Bon, ces preuves ne sont pas totalement concluantes
et même parmi les chercheurs en Toxo,
les opinions sont partagées :
ce parasite influence-t-il réellement notre comportement.
Mais compte tenu de la nature répandue de telles manipulations,
il serait impossible
que les humains soit la seule espèce
qui ne serait pas infectée.
Et je pense que cette capacité de toujours
saboter notre façon de penser sur le monde
rend les parasites encore plus extraordinaires.
Ils nous invitent à regarder le monde de coté
et à nous demander si les comportements que nous voyons,
qu'ils soient simples et flagrants,
ou déconcertant et déroutant,
sont le résultat non pas d'individus
exerçant leur libre arbitre
mais parce qu'ils y sont poussés
par le contrôle de quelque chose d'autre.
Et même si cette idée est inquiétante
et que ces parasites ont des habitudes qui peuvent sembler horribles,
je pense que cette capacité à nous surprendre
les rendent aussi merveilleux et aussi charismatiques
que n'importe quel panda, papillon ou dauphin.
A la fin de « De l'origine des espèces »,
Charles Darwin parle de la splendeur de la vie,
et de ces formes infinies toutes aussi belles
et toutes aussi formidables,
et j'aime à penser qu'il pouvait être en train de parler
d'un ver qui rend les crevettes sociables
ou d'une guêpe qui emmène les cafards se balader.
Mais ce n'est peut-être qu'un parasite qui parle.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)